حسمت الحكومه الفرنسيه امرها ومررت مشروع
قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد من دون تصويت
البرلمان ما فجر تظاهرات غاضبه عفويه امام
البرلمان انضم اليها نواب اليسار الفرنسي
في الطريق الى التظاهره وقف نواب اليسار
على بعد امتار من حاجز امني وردد النشيد
الوطني بعدها بدقائق وصل الزعيم اليساري
الاكثر جدلا وشعبيه في فرنسا جانوك
ميلانشون لتتعالى صيحات الترحيب به
شده سنقوم بطرح مذكره حجب ثقه عن الحكومه
هذا نص ليست له شرعيه تم اعتماده في مجلس
الشيوخ لكن لم يوافق عليه مجلس النواب
تمرير الحكومه لمشروعها من دون تصويت مجلس
النواب كان خيارا لكنه لم يكن متوقعا بهذا
الشكل فلوحت المعارضه اليساريه بمذكرات
حجم الثقه عن الحكومه وكذلك فعلت زعيمه
اقصى اليمين مارين لوبتان
هناك نواب من كتله الاكثريه الرئاسيه
معارضون لمشروع القانون تم تهديدهم
لاجبارهم على التصويت بنعم هذا حصل ايضا
لدى الجمهوريين النقابات اعلنت جاهزيتها
للتصعيد بهدف الوصول الى شل الاقتصاد
سنقوم بشل الاقتصاد هذا ما نخطط لفعله
حاليا وايضا ستكون هناك تحركات في قطاع
الطاقه خصوصا البترول سنقوم بفعل كل شيء
لتصعيد الغضب
بذلك تدخل فرنسا مرحله جديده من عداء شارع
المعارضه للحكومه والرئيس ما قد ينذر
بانفجار شعبي سيتحمل الرئيس والحكومه
بعاته بحسب ما تهدد النقابات فدهوك
العربيه باريس